so why are these people losing it though
why why are they losing it whether it
comes to
gender
or abortion
or that everyone that's going to win is
unelectable it's because they're losing
americans and they almost sort of got it
right there
on the view the clip that i showed you
previously where sunny was like oh and
it does look like latinos are uh voting
republican now as we know mayra flores
just crushed it in texas to be the next
congresswoman in a district that was a
hundred years of democrat control
they're losing everybody
and partly it's because nobody believes
that joe biden is a functional president
right now but don't tell that to joe
biden mr president what's your message
to democrats who don't want you to run
again
they want me to run two thirds say they
don't
read the polls jack you guys are all the
same that poll showed that 92 percent of
democrats of iran would vote for me a
majority of democrats say they don't
want you to run again in 2024. 92 said
if i did they'd go
i mean he completely made that up he
completely made that up we showed you a
cnn poll from yesterday cnn is not
thrilled to have to show you a poll
about a democrat president not doing
well that was it 96 percent guys was it
96 percent of democrats under the age of
30 do not want him to run
on top of the fact that just think about
you don't need polls on this just think
about in your life do you know anyone
that really wants joe biden to run again
do you know anyone that thinks joe
biden's doing a particularly good job
the only two people so far that publicly
i know want joe biden to run again are
pete k pete because he wants to keep his
job and kamala because she wants to keep
her job but she's just lying all along
because she wants him out so she can
take over and then why does she want to
take over not because she thinks not
because she has a vision for the country
or is competent or anything else but the
people pulling her strings whoever those
people might be will be pretty thrilled
to have a sort of more mindless buffoon
than joe biden in